I hate it when movies do this dude this
is true craftsmanship and true art right
here oh my god dude I can tell you
exactly how they did this thanks
three-cone for sponsoring this video
stick around to the end of the episode
to figure out you can get 15% off your
first order hi everyone welcome back to
another episode of visual effects artist
react now you might be saying to
yourself wait a minute a new episode you
guys are sitting right next to each
other in this quarantine ha this is a
trigger perspective we are in fact quite
distant from each other and we will be
giving you an episode here socially
distance at the corridor digital studios
where all want you home these days but
we had to come back in order to film
this one thing we said quite distance
but how distance Nikko justice our way
oh this is exactly don't let them
breathe on that so a little further than
about six feet there we have it Co get
that near me the friends are about seven
and a half anyways we got a lot of great
clips for you guys today we got some
good stuff we got some bad stuff we got
everything in between it's gonna be good
let's break it down and tell you guys
how they made the magic and how they
maybe have made the magic even better
movie splash starring Tom Hanks it came
out I don't know 50 years ago it's
currently up on Disney Plus but because
that's a family-friendly network they
actually had to track in some CG hair
over her her but as she goes running off
into the haha that is rough and it kind
of just makes everyone ask why I can
tell you exactly how they did this so
that is the clone tool probably an After
Effects we've cloned one spot of her
hair literally over and over so that is
her hair rocks all the hair rocks on her
but the same way just a up the video
clone tool oh boy that is a flat 2d car
does she like dives in this seeing this
on Twitter today made me realize I have
no idea what the original shot was maybe
we saw a little bit more
the hair bikini looks real like that
definitely that's nothing practical I
could see him being like ooh when she
dies into the water and back in the day
they're just like whatever release it
but it would've been so much easier for
Disney just to fix that a little bit
with the clone tool rather than cloning
a giant fur Pelt over her entire keister
the problem with this is that it comes
down to the effect is just very obvious
yeah and the clip has gone viral because
it's obvious and has drawn everyone's
attention and now it's become a greater
problem than they initially bargained
for but that's because that's how these
things work
whoa studies papa I I have yet to watch
this same I have yet to actually watch
this I've been meaning to I start a part
five is finally up the guy finally got
his YouTube channel back and under
control which is great because it was
lost for a while hey guess what it still
looks excellent it's beautiful man the
crazy thing about a star DS is it's
basically one dude I mean there's a
couple other guys that like helped out
here and there were some things but this
is a testament to knowing your workflow
and knowing how to like solve problems
in an efficient way
did that surface imperfections on the
shoulder mmm so nice
all that service yeah let this placement
map yeahit's do you think that's a
displacement map or an actual like model
definitely displacement map displacement
maps are super super cool because
displacement map so they basically let
you do is they let you take a texture
and they let you deform something
geometrically based on that texture is
basically based off of like a luminance
value so the darker something is the
more sunken into the object it goes in
the brighter the pixel the more away
from the object it goes Renne you made a
really cool lego brick about your leg
over using just this placement mask yeah
so like just using a displacement map
you can turn just a box model like
literally just six polygons into like a
highly detailed Lego brick because and
actually have like the little circles go
up and then if you're to flip the whole
cube over you have like the whole insect
cube going in and you actually make a
whole leg over it because simulating all
of that all of that geometry would have
just broken the system right yeah
because we had to simulate like
literally thousands of LEGO bricks
falling down I'm simulating a cube is
easy but simulating a Hugh Blythe pegs
on the top and hollow things on the
bottom that's hard exactly the computer
thinks is a cube but we think it's a
Lego brick thanks to the displacement
man it's a way to get tons of extra
detail without having to like overtaxed
your system
dude whatever this look is modeling and
I thought that he put helmets on these
guys just to be like you know what I'm
not the best at you know facial
information so I'll just rock with some
helmets and some armor but no he just
took his helmet off guys is there any
motion capture in this I guess that's
nobody so I think this is all hand
keyframed I think I think so when you're
animating like an actual fully CG
character there's so many different
things you have to like keyframe over
the time like every joint every position
of every arm everything has to be like
intentionally placed in order to create
the motion that's why people use motion
capture suits or motion capture studios
to streamline all of that data so that I
can like do this and then it's captured
obviously there's some work going into
translating and converting that stuff I
would be surprised if somebody helped
out maybe gave him some base animations
but even still like there's so many
specific things that you can't really do
with motion capture that he has here
there's specific timed animations the
finger twitch there like guys the guys
like going in people for example yeah
one of the crazy things about this being
animated is the the armor you need to
make it sure that I guess things move
that they don't clip and like you know
you'll have rigged bodies that will
deform you know basically the skin down
to a bone system but with armor you need
to have things that stay solid and they
all need to like work together and move
correctly and overlap with each other
and you can always tell a good animator
because they keep inertia and momentum
into account like let's say I have a
carrot I want them to punch and like you
know okay so they're here and they go
here right what's so hard about that
animation in real life you have to
accelerate and then you have to
decelerate and you know it throws your
body into it in your head you know gets
pulled chin hurts and then when your
forehead follows afterwards and all
these weird little rules about how
things move apply to animation and you
said to have broken down the universe
effectively to understand all these
little tricks it's one of those things
was like an animator who's done a lot of
animating a walk around be like oh I can
see how that thing swings a little bit
differently because that thing moved the
way that person moved cause this little
thing to move differently over there
some of those weird little curses you
have to live with
I don't know bout you guys but I walk
around looking at things back okay so if
I were to replicate it's the material I
would need a bump map do the same thing
interesting like you can do that with a
noise map you can stretching on the
y-axis a little bit and like I totally
didn't seem like I want to recreate this
texture just on a walk and Kim's like
hey hey pay attention - I'm sorry I was
just staring at the ground
[Laughter]
so I think at a certain point you know
you get to the point where it's pretty
easy to make something look really nice
but what sets this above everything else
is the composition and the lighting and
the shot structure and the editing like
it's all so well done you know it's not
just oh this model looks nice it's no
look at this beautiful world put
together brilliantly
composed brilliantly edited together
just in an amazing way this is this is
true true craftsmanship and true art
right here this guy has a patreon I'm a
supporter of him on patreon I really
want to see him make more stuff well the
link in the description below if you
guys want to help this guy make more of
these things yeah are you guys enjoying
the content so far good when I want you
that subscribe button we got a whole
bunch more for you Indian Jones oh my
god dude and I was watching the
originals in quarantine it's the best
movies
here we go red buckle up oh my god
physics don't matter bad green-screen
screen it looks janky to me because
first off you have this light wrapping
of the background kind of bleeding into
their hair the the side of the window
their shoulders everything is just
evenly wrapped around and it looks it
just looks off look super off to me the
background is like dim like really dim
the colors are weird it's the whole King
Kong ring from the dinosaurs sequence
problem where it's just like weird fuzzy
mats everything is light wrap like like
that live-action yeah is static her
hair's not even blowing in the wind yeah
it's just a classic issue though of like
green screen in an environment that's
really dynamic and the green screen is
nowhere near as dynamic as the
environment because this is coming off
you know the prequels where they did a
whole lot of blue screen green screen
like well fix it in post and like they
just kept that attitude here and just it
feels lazy it feels like they're on set
they're just like okay well let's fix it
in post like you know they have like
hundreds of people with like you know
costing them thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars doing the effects
but they can't be bothered to put a fan
it's just obvious that they're not doing
this for real and it takes you out of
the movie you establish rules in your
world but if you violate those rules you
violate your world and therefore the
story doesn't really matter anymore the
stakes don't really matter like in some
films you can do this Mary Poppins you
can do this Indiana Jones physics need
to matter otherwise his daring stunts
don't matter like if everything's Looney
Tunes cartoon and then somebody jumping
from one car to another it's not a big
deal and they've established clearly
clearly that were in Looney Tunes land
so like the dude jumping off the back of
the car then MIG on the edge of the
cliff there's zero stakes because if
they drive off the cliff they're just
wily coyote they're way back onto the
road somehow at least that's how it
feels it's like they're being real
physical consequences I mean this is the
movie that had Harrison Ford's private
nuke what getting in her fridge so it's
not really following the rules but it's
just compared dude compared to the
originals man this is like what is this
dude like this compared to the tank
chase oh yeah
dude yeah anytime like hanging on to
that that turret and getting scraped
against the rock does it go hard it's
getting closer and closer like that's so
intense compared to just cg world and
you're like yeah it doesn't matter
I just remembered when you guys left a
comment for this very next scene if you
guys have a scene you'd like us to react
to I'll leave a comment will react to it
very next episode
my kids my kids 3d this is back before
like 3d movies and theaters for
commonplace Robert Rodriguez just screw
it it's a kids movie I'll just get her
done this guy's freaking desk that is
death I hate it when movies do this dude
they do that fricking janky super
gimmicky 3d move no Joss 3d as well so I
guess this whole movie is based on the
gimmick of 3d which is why they have
things like sparks flying to camera
because it feels like it's actually
coming through the movie screening
hitting you in the face
whereas most commonly over the last
decade or so 3d movies have all been
about extending the set behind the
screen and giving depth Dino wise Cheech
or whatever his name is
in this Danny Trejo machete Shetty
till you show me flying it or a pig
bill paxton our IP these are like the
code an Adam Sandler movie but for
Robert Rodriguez forgets all his friends
together and they just goof around but
you know what the fact that it's a kids
movie means it's like pretty chill like
they're clearly on a green screen the
whole time
wait are those CG glasses because they
weren't wearing them a moment ago so
there's a cut there
so CG glasses there there's a cut right
okay so it's just a jump cut okay okay
this is a justified 3d shot in my piggy
mm-hmm that's justified those perfectly
glossy metallic robot I know this is
basically Pacific Rim now at this point
can you forgive yourself it's never too
late semester oh that's great
[Music]
Hakan these timepieces fall off so a
huge thing for my inspiration when I'm
jumping into say like a visual effect
shot I'm trying to get creative and
write something awesome
the very first thing I'll do is pop in
some earbuds and listen to some music
and that's why today's sponsor Drakon is
a perfect fit they got these awesome
everyday e25 earbuds these are about
half the price of any other wireless
earbuds the quality is just incredible
is if not better got a bunch of awesome
colors nice design you got six hours of
battery life and they're got a real nice
cozy fit they just fit right in your ear
so if you guys are like myself and you
need to listen to music to get inspired
the rake on every dayi twenty-five
earbuds are a great way to do that if
you guys are looking for a pair for
yourselves head to buy rake on Comm
slash corridor crew or click the link in
the description to find out how you can
get 15% off your first rake on order
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody we've
officially ran out of footage so we've
had to start recording new episodes here
we're doing it as safe as we can we hope
you are staying safe as well but we'll
still be here every Saturday to
entertain you let me see your quarantine
haircuts not bad Renne looking kinda
almost a little bit fro yeah can I go
see if I can stick my hair out and like
dude that's like a wall dude Narwhal
anyways please consider subscribing if
you have not already I look forward to
hanging out with you guys in the next
one